the night is dark and full of Terrors
Joe Biden 2024 Biden kicking off 2024 by
delving into some of the country's
darkest moments uh this guy is going to
Valley Forge
Pennsylvania where George Washington in
the Continental Army spent a bleak
winter near 250 years ago okay then he's
going to Mother Emanuel Church in
Charleston where nine people were shot
and killed in a June 15 supremacist
attack oh boy it's not exactly the Fun
Run is it that's where he's starting
he's starting there where do you go if
you start at Valley Forge only up only
up you'd think you would think
Gettysburg yeah he might he might it
might get even worse he might leave the
country you might see the next
commercial he does might be from asz you
know I'm Joe Biden here at
awz